sas à la chambre que la p tite
bisman nseries son conjoint sont famille
d'accueil depuis 2020 ils ont hébergé
six enfants à ce jour ça vous apporte
un sens elle adore ces petites ils ont
par exemple vu une fillette de 8 ans
d'abord timide s'épanouir au cours des
deux dernières années maintenant elle
est confiante elle a beaucoup d'amis
autour d'elle elle se laisse aller comme
un enfant comme ses amis comme des
familles comme celle de bizemont en
série la direction de la protection de
la jeunesse on cherche partout au québec
sur le territoire du sud de l'ouest de
l'île de montréal la pénurie est
préoccupante selon cette gestionnaire
donc j'ai treize familles qui pourraient
recevoir des enfants j'ai 44 enfants qui
attendent aucun de ces enfants là n'a de
correspondance avec les familles que
j'ai par contre pour être en situation
celle je devrais avoir 48 familles dans
ma barque donc si jamais on n'a eu
d'autres enfants et s'est trouvé des
familles est d'autant plus compliquée
depuis que l'esprit de la nouvelle loi
sur la protection de la jeunesse exige
que les fratries soient placés au même
endroit bisman une série son conjoint
peuvent le faire mais ce n'est pas donné
à tous oui on veut que la fratrie son
ensemble mais est ce qu'il ya des
familles qui sont capables de prendre
plus qu'un enfant que je pense ça c'est
la partie qui est comme le plus grand
challenge pour le moment l'association
des familles d'accueil et des ressources
intermédiaires du québec croit que la
dpj devrait revoir son modèle de famille
idéale pour attirer de nouveaux
candidats et mieux les soutenir une fois
sélectionnés d'un maître l'her leurs
exigences aussi élevé ben ça fait en
sorte que plein de gens qui disent
cependant convenir bande à mario tama
retraites malgré tout pis mansory
encourage les familles à plonger même si
ce n'est pas facile tous les jours c'est
tellement gratifiant
ouvrir les portes de sa maison et aussi
de son coeur à des enfants qui en ont
besoin ici valérie michaela belle une
radio canada montréal